Speaker 1: We are now ready to talk about
the disastrous and humiliating aftermath of
the House Speaker fiasco.
Now, I don't know how many of you followed
it closely over the weekend.
I did not.
After a vote, number seven, I guess on Friday
or whatever day was, I just checked out and
said, I'm sure by Monday we will have figured
out what happened.
And indeed we have.
Kevin McCarthy was indeed elected speaker
of the House eventually on the 15th round
of voting, and it all became a farce.
It all became a joke.
There was a physical altercation on the House
floor in which Republican members were grabbing
each other.
It's completely surreal that this is what
happened.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE now, as a result, is
like abandoning.
Q and on and then the Q and on.
People are furious with Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE It's there's four or five or six different
layers of absurdity that now are following
what happened on the floor of the House of
Representatives.
But they have a speaker, okay.
And it's Kevin McCarthy.
And one of the things we have to recognize
and I mean, ideally they would recognize it
in the Republican Party, I'm not sure they
do, is that they have weakened the speakership
to its weakest point, certainly in decades,
in the decades that many of us have been following
politics, people who are roughly my age, this
is now a speakership that is more of a joke
than it has ever been before.
This is a speakership that is weaker in terms
of its ability and power at coalescing consensus
between even their own party.
And you don't need to look very far to see
how quickly this entire thing became a joke.
Shortly after the big win for Kevin McCarthy,
he announced the very first thing that they
would be doing and listen to what it was.
Speaker 2: I know the night is late, but when
we come back, our very first bill will repeal
the funding for 87,000.
Speaker 1: And there's Marjorie Taylor GREENE
clapping.
Yeah, very, like, just painfully stupid.
Now, I've already debunked the whole thing
about the IRS agents.
It's I'm not going to do it now because it's
not the point.
But we have so many different and important
issues in this country that we could be working
towards fixing.
And the idea that the American people would
even remotely benefit from that as opposed
to anything else is laughable.
One other funny moment when it was announced
that Donald Trump got one vote during one
of the votes for speaker, I believe it was
Matt Gaetz.
The entire room just laughs.
Speaker 2: The Honorable Donald J. Trump of
the State of Florida has received one.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it really is a joke.
The entire thing has turned into a joke, and
obviously it was also a political drama of
the highest order.
It got clicks, it got ratings.
But the entire speaker fiasco, really, at
the end of the day, is an exercise in extreme
irony.
And one of our subreddit users, Wrong, sir.
Wrong, pointed out a lot of the ways in which
this was extraordinarily ironic.
So I'm going to use their post as a jumping
off point here to talk more about this.
The 20 House members who initially defected,
for lack of a better term, in a way, they
are the ones standing by their principles
in the sense that they are some of the most
insane and extreme members of the House.
Kevin McCarthy was very much willing to trade
votes for power or influence, and he did it
based on what we've been told with committee
assignments and with other things.
Those 20 to the extent that they stuck it
out, they weren't willing to trade assignments
or whatever for votes because they thought
that Kevin McCarthy was a terrible candidate.
Now, the reason they thought that is because
McCarthy isn't nearly as extreme as they are.
Right.
So we have to understand that's really bonkers.
But they at least had some principle, principle
where so many of these other people have absolutely
no principles whatsoever.
That's been a theme of the last many years.
These Republicans sort of claim to have values,
but they really don't.
It's whatever values are convenient to them
at the time.
And as soon as those values are inconvenient
or inconsistent with getting what they need
in terms of power, they abandon the values.
We saw this 180 that Marjorie Taylor GREENE
did.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE After years of portraying
herself as I'm anti-establishment, I'm not
a sellout.
I'm against rhinos, all of this stuff.
She does a 180 and she supports Kevin McCarthy,
who is the Republican establishment, because
it seems as though McCarthy promised her a
sliver of influence if he wins and she's going
to get back on some committee assignments
and whatever else the case may be, That's
extraordinarily ironic.
And another example of how they don't really
have principles.
Marjorie Taylor Greene's principles are really
the creation of a character that she believes
will be a character that can gain power and
influence also.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE has been criticizing
defecting Republicans for not playing ball
and wanting attention, But that's exactly
what Marjorie Taylor GREENE did to get herself
to where she is now.
She has been the epitome of the attention
seeker, and now she's criticizing others for
trying to get attention.
We're going to look at an interview later
in which Marjorie Taylor GREENE actually says
this.
You know, all these holdouts were just trying
to get attention.
Well, everything you've done has been to get
attention, and now all of a sudden you're
getting attention because you say that they
are doing the wrong thing and you're doing
the right thing.
And then Kevin McCarthy, of course, by appeasing
Marjorie Taylor GREENE now creates a generation
of Marjorie Taylor GREENE wannabes in Congress
who will make a show out of obstructing as
much as possible and then eventually coming
to the table, getting some things, some crumbs
in the negotiations and subsequently getting
power.
First, you yell, you yell, you yell to get
attention.
Then you say, well, you're going to want to
make me go away.
Give me some power.
And so now that's going to encourage more
and more people to do that.
And then lastly, as again is pointed out by
this user on our subreddit, wrongs are wrong.
For years and years, McCarthy groveled to
Trump.
He wanted Trump to endorse him for the speakership.
Groveling, groveling.
Trump did the endorsement sort of half heartedly.
At the end of the day, if we're honest.
But Trump did the endorsement.
But it turns out that that endorsement didn't
even get McCarthy the speakership.
Trump did the endorsement on I think it was
Wednesday night and many, many, many more
votes in which McCarthy lost.
Eventually, it was a different sort of negotiation
that got McCarthy the speakership.
So it's another sign of how through his endorsement,
we actually notice that Trump is even more
weakened than we previously thought.
And it's irony all the way down, quite frankly.
This is a very inauspicious start for the
next two years.
And we know they're going to go after Joe
Biden.
We know they're going to go after Hunter Biden.
We know they're going to obstruct everything
they can.
And so now Democrats are going to have to
think long and hard, to use Donald Trump's
phrase, about what is the best way to get
the most possible out of the next two years
and to mitigate damage to the extent that
they can.